[Music]
love that all right it's your it's not
your average donut shop okay as you can
see and what better way to celebrate
national donut day one of my favorite
days of the year than with vegas's most
couture most fabulous donuts saint
honore welcome michael thank you very
much how are you oh i'm good i'm great
i'm tempted as we were talking about
earlier in the show it is temptation
sunday's coming up temptation every day
when donuts are around for sure
all right so we let's talk about the
clip that we just saw that was one from
your tick tock you and your wife you
guys have built this incredible
delicious empire you know how has that
helped you guys with your donuts and
with your creations well tick tock's
definitely uh changed the the scene for
marketing right so it's definitely
driving guests into the restaurant the
product obviously is helping a lot and
and our partners have been a huge help
in creating this awesome concept so it's
four of us myself alex my wife and steve
uh we're excited to celebrate our three
year anniversary with national donut day
uh join us on social for some free
giveaways definitely doing some fun
stuff there and then we have some uh
minis that we have going on in the
restaurant too to have to help celebrate
our anniversary and national donation
okay so what makes them couture so our
dough is brilliant off the runway that's
right our dough is brioche dough it's 24
hours we have to uh mix by hand and
obviously it um it rises and proofs
overnight then our staff comes in rolls
it out by hand cuts it by hand fries it
and then decorates these beauties by
hand everything everything is done with
a lot of love uh the concept behind a
lot of these donuts are french pastries
re-envisioned as a doughnut okay so give
us an example let's
give your dough
you have a dopolion right here which is
our take on a french you know a french
classic um we have you know our boston
cream which is in the donut here uh we
have our um uh i'm drawing blank right
now the
salted caramel right here
and we have
queenie right here as well well which
one do you suggest that i uh do you like
nutella what's what's the most popular
you like nutella yeah yeah i'm right
here
and i hear that there's some celebrities
who are big fans of you guys who who
comes in
and shops with you well let's see we do
a lot of deliveries they don't
necessarily come in and shop we've done
uh mr buble john legends uh a few a few
popular folks on tick-tock okay okay
yeah
let's let us know
what do you think oh my god did you get
nutella
yes i did
wow
oh my god okay now i'm gonna have to try
and talk with this in my mouth but i
hear they're gluten-free as well right
we have gluten-free options as well
correct
jc that's for you that's for you now
tell everybody how they can come visit
and what kind of vibe are they going to
get when they walk into the shop so
located on tibetan flamingo
9460 west flamingo is the address coming
in you're going to have hip hop music
playing a very uh open environment all
the donuts are on display on the glass
case and the staff's ready to help you
and sell you some great donuts speaking
of hip hop i know a snoop dogg is a fan
too he is a fan he's a fan huh what does
he order
snoop likes chocolate
anything and everything chocolate he has
munchies quite often
well thank you so much michael thank you
guys thanks for having us i'm gonna take
this entire platter for myself you guys
can
you guys can choose from the other
platter enjoy guys thank you very much
happiness day